my name is Melissa true and I am
director of the Asia Society Museum i
was born in darwin australia it's a far
northern city and i spent most of my
childhood in this place and then my
mother believed that we should move
south to sydney to be educated so i
spent most of my life in sydney in fact
and just over six years ago I moved here
to New York when I was offered a
position at asia society my father is
originally from mainland China in fact
from the south of China near Guangzhou
and his family story is that they moved
from southern China into Hong Kong when
the Communists came to power in China
and he subsequently moved to Australia
for his university education and my
mother is Australian of anga Celtic
heritage well I think that my first
contact was even not so much with China
but more with Hong Kong because my
father's family were based there we
would spend a lot of time in hong kong
at least visiting our families and
relatively and relatives there and so I
think that Hong Kong in many ways is a
what you might call a China in diaspora
so it's China but it's also a little bit
different because it has an experienced
the same kinds of things that mainland
China that have defined modern mainland
China such as the Cultural Revolution I
think that my upbringing was unusual in
that like most children of that time and
certainly in Australia I think that what
had happened was that my father very
much wanted his children to be
Australian and so I think my mother
really wanted us to be Chinese in
influencing my father really wanted us
to be Australian so I come from very
much a kind of biracial household
my first visit to China was in 1992 with
my father he he wanted to take me to
China to show me the Three Gorges he was
convinced that the three gorges dam
would have a substantial impact on the
surrounding cities and things like that
so he wanted to show his children that
kind of experience and during that time
I did see some artists and I was
impressed with the work and also
impressed with the circumstance the
their ability to produce works to create
things in what was an extremely
difficult environment at that time and
this was post daily 9 the Tiananmen
incident and so things were pretty
stripped then I think that from very
early childhood my I had always shown an
interest in art and I think that my
parents had always encouraged that and
so when it came for all of us to make
decisions about what part our career
might take I decided to study in art
history and when I was going through
University at that time in Australia
Austria was really undergoing a an
enormous kind of readjust mental
realignment where those those powers
that be in politics and in the financial
fields really wanted to see Australia
realign itself to the asia-pacific
region realizing that the US and
European markets primarily were becoming
harder for Australia to engage with and
so I was very much involved in seeing
that kind of climate change and I had
long obviously traveled to Asia through
my family's experiences and so I became
interested more and more interested in
China and also asian report
you